talk to my wife about this you know and
I'm really open with my wife like we
have we have you know we've been married
10 years right and we've been together
for 13 years so we have four kids and
I'm like I'd say like I don't know what
how I would react to that it's like I
would like to believe the best of myself
like I would like to believe that I
would hold myself the highest standard
and certainly like I realize there's
always opportunities but like I've never
had like two cheerleaders
dressed like scandily and beautifully
like walk up to me and be like hey what
are you doing right now let's go back to
our hotel I'd just be like uh like I
don't know what my brain would do like I
would like to believe the highest of
myself I really would and I'd like to
say hey I'm gonna I'm gonna make the
right decision but I'm not tempted at
that level you know what I mean like
when things are transpiring and
escalating I can catch on pretty quick
like ah she's giving me the eye this
isn't that this is different yeah